this is a pretty main question in that
you know what this is it's a straight
line and depending on what K is if K was
say zero
it'd be just y equals x you're like I
don't like with X look like as K changes
it just moves up and down this guy
though um you you never have to graph or
work with something like this I know
because I've I've done the higher levels
I know this is an ellipse but you don't
know that you're like oh I don't even
know what's going on right so therefore
that's why this question is a bit of a
curveball but one of the unusual things
about it is we can still solve it
without without any such knowledge of
actually what this looks like I'll show
you what it looks like in a minute if we
are looking for solutions and it's
simultaneous equations then clearly the
first step is I should try and combine
these in some kind of way and then see
what happens right so that's my first
instinct I might not be able to get an
answer out of this but I could at least
probably get a mark by saying if it has
something to do with solutions I'm gonna
have to attempt to solve this now Y is
already the subject over here so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
substitute into equation 2 so I'll write
that I'll sub 1 into 2 okay so what that
gives me is 2x squared is still hanging
out the front here is what I'm gonna put
in place of Y so K plus x squared equals
6 mm-hmm all right now at this point if
they're really being nice to me I might
even get a mark at this point but what
what is this what am I just created
X or Y variables but K is the constant
so therefore when you look at this this
is an equation with X and it's a
quadratic equation you see that
everything is is in squares right and
I'm really good at dealing with
quadratic equations I can find how many
solutions there are to a quadratic based
on now which piece of knowledge do we
use in quadratic Theory right to work
out whether a quadratic equation has no
solutions or one solution or two what do
I use I'm gonna use the discriminant so
to use the discriminant I'll put this
somewhere else the discriminant I have a
formula for this it's B
squared minus 4ac it's the thing
underneath the square root so in order
to use this I need it in in general for
ID the a and the B and the C and it's
not currently in general for so I only
need to work with this first thing we do
is expand it out ah let's see here okay
squared excuse me
okay now just before I move on how did I
know that expanding would be a good idea
and the answer is if I want to if I with
the a and the B and the C separately I'm
trying to head toward this form this is
general form and you can see it's
written in expanded form but the X
Squared's haven't gathered the X has
been gathered etc so let's see how many
things we can collect how many x squared
terms oh there's just um yeah two here
and one here so three x squared that's a
really missing X here I can see the X
terms in here 2k
that's how many lots of X there are now
the other thing I notice is that when it
comes to the constants they're all
gathered in this spot here and there are
no constants over here so I have to
change that
so it looks to me like I've got a K
squared but I'll subtract six through
both sides to make the right hand side 0
okay in some senses I'm pretty much the
hardest part of the question is done
I've got a I've got B I've got C so I
think that was the trickiest part of the
question to know this is what I should
do but we're still not out of the woods
yet so let's let's actually keep going
I've got my general form I can find my
distributor out of this I can find what
it is but I now need to look at the
question to say what do I want the
discriminant to be so if they're
describing it the description could be
one of three things it could be less
than zero it can be equal to zero or it
can be greater than zero remember which
ones which yeah that certs one solution
when it just touches this is where the
thing under the square root is negative
so you get no solutions or zero and so
this is the one we actually want this is
the one where you get two solutions
so I'm good I'm gonna go with that I've
got to say what is the discriminant I
want it to be greater than zero so let's
do that in this case b squared is 2 K or
squared minus 4 lots of there's a and
there's C and that's greater than zero
now you're starting to realize why this
question is three bucks because in
solving this I've created another coach
had a new agent that's quite a lot of
work right but we could do it so over
here that's going to be 4 K squared
minus 12 lots of this so I'm just I'm
just trying to do the algebra here okay
now I'm just going to watch out this
double bang if that's the only reason
why I didn't do the more than one hip
there's 4 K squared here take away 12 K
squared plus 72 that looks good
collect like terms so minus 8 K squared
at this point what's your instinct what
should i do at this point
I can already solve for K so I'm quite
questing getting there it's a quadratic
so I probably want to end up factorizing
I'm just gonna get that line so I've got
a common factor there what's the common
factor that makes the mrs. negative 8 so
if I divide through by that negative H
that'll become minus 9 and then because
some negative number my inequality
switches direction and then I can
factorize so this is going to be
difference of squares what do I get K
minus 3 k plus 3 I want to be less than
zero and so now I imagine what does this
look like you can probably do this bit
in your head but this guy looks like
this oh that's really bad scale but you
get the idea I want it to be less than
zero so that's this part down
yeah that's okay the rest of its great
zero so therefore my solution is between
negative 3 & 3 so that is a lot of work
let's just rewind back to the start okay
I would expect hmm just thank you to
myself ok so 1 mark is here for your
actual solution I would expect somewhere
in here probably here to be honest this
is where number 1 I've demonstrated I
know what the discriminant is number 2
I've demonstrated what I what to do with
the discriminant and X that is a lot of
it that's why you're in a hallmark for
it your last mark I'd say is probably
somewhere around here in terms of
knowing that you need to solve them
simultaneously and not just doing that I
think it's quite easy like well then
where do I go with that to know that I'm
getting on a general form demonstrates
an understanding of how to use the
discriminant basically so that that's
why there's this so much
sorry marks aside to this question